trees from a forest in central mexico
are being harvested for timber
the images don't exactly evoke a sense
of conservation
but several communities who reside near
the outskirts of this forest have found
that sustainable timber harvest and land
protection go hand in hand
this harvest generates economic gains
for the community which are distributed
in percentages for social projects and
most importantly for reforestation and
creating conservation brigades to
protect against forest fires
the pine trees being hauled away are
taken to a sawmill
here the sale of wood has brought steady
income to almost a dozen communities
known as ajidos
under mexican agrarian law ejitos have
communal ownership over the forest and
are entrusted with protecting it
organization 11 is a part of our
organization they all abide by the rules
of forestry management which determine
precisely how much wood can be extracted
annually
with the rainy season underway
reforestation efforts are in full swing
and the mexican government is providing
assistance in the form of pine saplings
it's a model of sustainability that's
existed in mexico for hundreds of years
when a community sees the forest as
their livelihood they have an incentive
to preserve it and protect it from fires
illegal logging and caring for the
biodiversity inside the forest
community investment in ecotourism has
also brought jobs to the region
there are concerns however that many
here don't feel safe speaking to
reporters about on camera
especially given the encroachment by
criminal groups known for illegally
exploiting agricultural lands and
forests
illegal logging continues to be a big
problem in some parts of the country but
here in central mexico community
management of natural resources has
proven to be an effective way of
protecting forests and promoting
sustainable development
more than 30 percent of mexico is
covered by forests and dedicated
conservation efforts are crucial for
their survival at least this forest
counts on the full-time stewardship of
its human guardians
manuel rapalo al jazeera mexico's
amanalco forest